y at-il à bonjour qu at-on appris
aujourd'hui
et bien aujourd'hui l'audition d'hier
matin a été reporté puisque le prévenu
n'a pas trop vite comme vous le disiez
il s'agit d'un ancien chef de service de
la dsi qui évoque le contexte avant les
attentats
donc plutôt concernant les frères kwasi
c'est-à-dire leur parcours on a appris
que chérif kouachi et donc avait tenté
de partir en irak en 2004 il s'est fait
attraper donc a écopé de trois ans de
prison c'est donc durant son
incarcération qui l'a rencontré à mehdi
coulibaly en 2005 et 2006 il est reparti
en 2011 on en a su plus a également sur
le parcours en syrie die est beau mais
diana qui s'étaient échappés juste avant
les attentats
et bien à une médiane s'est remarié
n'est ce pas avec un mari tunisien et
une coépouse et ensuite au fil du recul
de l'état islamique elle a été placée
dans un camp dont elle s'est échappée le
camp des loges au roja va donc qui était
surveillé par les autorités kurdes et
donc elle sait elle s'est échappée alors
pourquoi ne t'ont pas aller la chercher
puis ce qu'on pouvait imaginer que des
fans de djihadistes s'y trouvaient lors
cela tout c'est toute la question en
tout cas d'autres questions ont été
posées à l'âge où la dgsi c'est à dire
pourquoi at on arrêté les surveillances
des frères cauchy un peu avant les
attentats et bien l'agencé justifié en
expliquant que le suivi des frères
cauchy avait duré très longtemps et qui
s'il avait 6 ans avait fait plus il
aurait été épinglés car les chefs de
services et agents doivent justifier les
écoute toutes les procédures et c'est
extrêmement lourd at il expliqué je vous
le site
on a essayé de rester le plus longtemps
possible pour voir quelque chose c'est
un regret d'avoir fait tout ce travail
et de ne pas risque de ne pas avoir
réussi à coincer les kwasi donc ils les
ont filé les ont écoutés et comme il
était très discret n'ont pas eu de
résultats n'ont pas eu le résultat qui
aurait été la suspicion d'un passage à
l'acte
donc c'est pourquoi ils ont fait chou
blanc il a également expliqué qu'il y
avait aujourd'hui 8000
radicaliser à potentialité violente en
france contre quelques dizaines
seulement en 2014
il a expliqué également qu'on ne peut
pas suivre tout le monde de manière
physique
voilà pour des nouvelles qui ne sont pas
très rassurantes